TODAY IS THE FINAL DAY OF
BUSINESS AND FINAL DAY OF
EXISTENCE FOR THE JANUARY 6th
HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE.
MOMENTS AGO THE PANEL RELEASED
MORE STUNNING TEXT MESSAGES AND
PUT OUT A NEW STATEMENT SUMMING
UP THEIR WORK.
THEY WROTE "WE OVERCAME MANY
HURDLES INCLUDING EFFORTS TO
CONCEAL, OBSTRUCT OUR WORK AND
MORE THAN A DOZEN LAWSUITS, MANY
WITNESSES HID BEHIND CLAIMS OF
PRIVILEGE INCLUDING DONALD TRUMP
HIMSELF WHO INITIALLY BLUSTERED
HE WOULD BE WILLING TO TESTIFY
THEN SUED SO HE COULD ACTUALLY
AVOID FACING OUR QUESTIONS."
BREAK IT ALL DOWN WITH TOM
FOREMAN AT THE WALL FOR US.
TOM, WALK US THROUGH SOME OF
THESE NEW TEXT MESSAGES JUST
RELEASED.
PRETTY INTERESTING.
>> Reporter: CERTAINLY ARE.
IF YOU HAVE ANY DOUBT THE PEOPLE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE KNEW WHAT WAS
HAPPENING AND HOW ACCOUNTABLE
THEY BE JUST LOOK AT THE TEXT
MESSAGES FROM ONE OF THE
PRESIDENT'S LONGEST MOST TRUSTED
ADVISERS HOPE HICKS TO ANOTHER
ON THAT DAY WRITING IN ONE DAY
HE ENDED EVERY FUTURE
OPPORTUNITY THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE
SPEAKING ENGAGEMENTS AT THE
LOCAL PROUD BOYS CHAPTER.
EXTREMIST FAR RIGHT GROUP AND SO
WILL BE PERPETUALLY UNEMPLOYED.
I'M SO UPSET.
WE ALL NOW LOOK LIKE DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS NOW.
ABBY, DOWN TO THEORETICALLY
DRIBS AND DRABS WHAT'S COMING
OUT OF THIS BIG INVESTIGATION OF
JANUARY 6, THE COMMITTEE HAS
DONE, STILL GETTING NEW
INFORMATION FROM MY MY -- FORME
CHIEF OF STAFF MARK MEADOWS.
>> VERY INTERESTING SHE'S
WORRIED ABOUT JOBS ON JANUARY
6th.
AND PROVIDING TEXT MESSAGES
EMAILS.
MARK MEADOWS.
WHAT MORE ARE WE LEARNING FROM
THOUSANDS DOCUMENTS?
>> WE'RE LEARNING DETAILS THE
COMMITTEE WANTED TO ASK HIM
ABOUT AND NEVER GOT THE CHANCE
TO.
FOR EXAMPLE, DECEMBER 23rd,
2020.
EMAIL SAID RUDY WAS PUT IN
CHARGE.
THAT WAS THE PRESIDENT'S
DECISION.
EXACTLY IN CHARGE OF WHAT, FOR
HOW LONG WHAT THAT EVERY
COMPASSED WE DON'T KNOW BUT WE
KNOW RUDY GIULIANI WAS VERY MUCH
INVOLVED IN THIS PLOT TO BRING
IN FAKE ELECTORS TRYING TO TURN
THINGS OVER.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT MEADOWS HAD AN
EMAIL FROM JANUARY 5th IN WHICH
HE INDICATED THAT THE NATIONAL
GUARD WOULD BE PRESENT AT THE
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6th TO
PROTECT PRO-TRUMP PEOPLE.
AGAIN, THIS IS ALL WITHOUT THE
CONTEXT THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE, THAT THE COMMITTEE WOULD
HAVE HAD AND WOULD HAVE HAD IF
MEADOWS CAME FORWARD TO TESTIFY
BUT HE DIDN'T.
AN THEN RONNA McDEATH SAID TO
THE COMMITTEE I DO HAVE
RECOLLECTION OF HIS, TRUMP,
ASKING WHAT MY RELATIONSHIP WAS
WITH THE VICE PRESIDENT.
I SAID, I DIDN'T KNOW HIM VERY
WELL.
IN REFERENCE TO THE IDEA WAS
THERE A WAY TO GET MIKE PENCE TO
DO WHAT TRUMP WANTED TO DO.
SHE WENT ON I BELIEVE PRIVATELY
OR ONE WAY OR THE OTHER THE VICE
PRESIDENT HAD THE AUTHORITY, I
DON'T KNOW THE CORRECT LEGAL
TERM, HE HAD AUTHORITY TO NOT
ACCEPT THE ELECTORS.
NOW, SHE HAS SAID SHE DIDN'T
KNOW THERE WAS AN ACTIVE PLAN TO
SWAP THESE ELECTORS ILLEGALLY,
MORE STANDBY ELECTORS BUT IT ALL
SPEAKS TO THE IDEA A LOT OF
PEOPLE, A LOT OF PEOPLE, ABBY,
KNEW WORKINGS OF THESE VARIOUS
PLOTS TO OVERTURNILLEGAL  --
A LEGAL ELECTION AND A LOT
CONCERNED ABOUT CONSEQUENCES IF
EXPOSED.
>> FASCINATING AND INTERESTING
THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS ASKING
RONNA McDANIEL ABOUT HER
RELATIONSHIP TO HIS OWN VICE
PRESIDENT.
>> EXACTLY.
RIGHT.
>> TOM, ANYTHING ELSE THAT
CAUGHT YOUR EYE IN THIS LATEST
BATCH OF TRANSCRIPTS?
>> A COUPLE THINGS CAME OUT.
THIS IS THE TAIL END OF IT SORT
OF.
REMARKABLE THINGS COMING OUT
CONSIDERING THIS IS BOTTOM OF
THE BARREL OF ALL STUFF
RELEASED'S ONE WAS REMEMBER
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON RIVETING
TALKING HOW TRUMP LUNGED AT
FRONT OF THE PRESIDENTIAL LIMO
TRYING TO TURN THE WHEEL BECAUSE
HE WANTED TO JOIN THE CAPITOL
BE, WITH HIS PEOPLE.
TRYING TO START A FIGHT IN THE
CAR TRYING TO MAKE HIS CAR GO TO
THE CAPITOL.
ANOTHER AIDE, TRUMP TOLD HE
COULDN'T GO TO THE CAPITOL SORT
OF SHRUGGED IT POFF.
SAME MOMENT?
A DIFFERENT MOMENT?
SOMEBODY'S TESTIMONY NOT
ENTIRELY TRUE?
WE STILL DON'T KNOW.
STILL MANY, MANY QUESTIONS WHAT
HAPPENED THAT DAY AND INCREDIBLY
CLEAR GOING THROUGH THE LAST
DRIBS OF THE COMMITTEE'S REPORT,
POTENTIALLY CRIMINAL AND A LOT
OF THOUGHT AT THE VERY LEAST
VERY BAD CONSEQUENCES ATTACHED
TO IT.
>> YEAH.
AND SAID SO TO EACH OTHER
PRIVATELY, BUT NOT SO MUCH
PUBLICLY.
>> YEAH.
AND THAT WORRY, THAT WORRY ABOUT
BEING EMPLOYABLE IS A REAL
THING.
WHEN PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, ABBY.
PEOPLE IN THIS TOWN LINE UP WITH
A CANDIDATE, A PARTY, BUILDING
CAREERS BASED ON THAT RECORD.
THESE WERE PEOPLE SAYING WHAT HE
HAS DONE HAS DESTROYED ALL OF
OUR CAREERS BECAUSE NOBODY WILL
WANT TO BE ASSOCIATED WITH US.
>> YEAH.
TOM, I WOULD THINK THERE WOULD
ALSO BE A CONCERN ABOUT SAFETY
OF FOLKS ON THE CAPITOL.
>> OF COURSE, OF COURSE.
>> ABOUT OUR DEMOCRACY, BUT THAT
DIDN'T SEEM TO SHOW UP IN THE
TEXT MESSAGES EITHER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL OF
THAT, TOM FOREMAN.